[Music]
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring of
cipher
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie capping you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got a hand so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
ready
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
[Music]
you hear the thing when your lights off
can't talk heavy with a light joe might
win might lose or my draw
welcome to the combat talk haters in
love but it come back salt if you really
want it in the ring i'm going to send a
contract i'll knock his contacts out you
will feel mice trying to take a fight
viper ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting fender man
i'm swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make em pay the piper cause i
might go live like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a fool
production you'll be talking like you
want a new concussion to do the custom
attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
sound which i will serve having tipping
moving like a tire swerve out here
acting bad thank you michael jackson
even got his one and only homie capping
you a phony homie now you owe me action
have him sinking tony tony tony braxton
and they all want to talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for an instant
mama got hands so i'm ready for the
tension i'ma leave him ready you can
dance
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
[Music]
okay
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring or
cipher cause i'm spitting venom and i'm
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food reduction you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie captain you were phony homie
now you owe me action have him sinking
tony tony tony braxton and they all want
to talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant momma got hands on
bread for the tension i'ma leave him red
you can dance
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome to
presents
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
god gone send a contract out knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a viper ain't no competition in
the ring decipher cause i'm spitting
finger mental swinging fire talking
pickled peppers make them pay the piper
cause i might go look like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
food production you'll be talking like
you want a new concussion can i do the
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got hands so i'm ready for
the tension i'ma leave him read you
could dance
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
[Music]
let me know
[Music]
come back salt if you really want it in
the ring god gone send a contract i'll
knock his contacts out you will feel
mice trying to take a bite but ain't no
competition in the ring decipher cause
i'm spitting venom and i'm swinging fire
talking pickled peppers make them pay
the piper cause i might go look like a
rude discussion and deflate your chest
like a food production you'll be talking
like you want a new concussion and a due
to custom attitude adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
sound which i will serve heaven's
tipping moving like a swerve out here
acting bad thank you michael jackson
even got his one and only homie capping
you a phony homie now you owe me action
have him sinking tony tony tony braxton
and they all wanna talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for an instant
mama got hands so i'm ready for the
picture i'ma leave him red you could
dance to redemption
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
as tonight
[Music]
presented boxing
fights out
the combat talk haters in love with the
comeback salt if you really want it in
the ring god gonna send a contract out
knock his contacts out you will feel
mice trying to take a viper ain't no
competition in the ring or cipher cause
i'm spitting venom and i'm swinging fire
talking pickled peppers make him pay the
piper cause i might go look like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
fool production you'll be talking like
you want a new concussion to do the
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve
what's going on y'all can hear me
everybody here
welcome to another combat talk with the
king what's going on people
benevites versus lemieux oh this is
ridiculous this is gonna be a ridiculous
fight
god bless all right oh so what we
drinking on tonight
um went with a little bit of a classic
uh what is that watermelon
margarita
c mac
that's good sp was good sound off people
all right brian what's good
he said finally made it on saturday
that's what's going on yeah that's right
intro's still popping 21 people up in
here that's what's good
i was looking at a little bit of the um
[Music]
the ufc joint
and that was that was dope that was dope
let me see what's going on here
switching around hopping around channel
the channel channel surfing
i really hate showtime
pay-per-view
stay pay-per-views be
hard-headed be honest with you
what's up imax what's going on what's
going
phillip was good
classic drink for sure
you already know mayweather was gonna do
that to that boy
i was gonna watch it um
and then i said you know this that's
something i'll catch later because it
was an ex exhibition
not really keen on you know these dudes
doing exhibition if he was gonna do that
um
just do it for real but he's out in the
world getting paid everybody thought
that oh no mayweather ain't gonna get no
money nobody gonna fight him
sp with the five dollar super chat
what's up
king what's good here's five dollars to
get the night started definitely that's
what's up my brother
getting light started with some lotion
on these ashy knuckles
[Laughter]
can't be having no ashy knuckles or no
show this is this is ridiculous
i really hate
showtime's um
pay-per-view portal like uh espn's
pay-per-view portal is is a little bit
different
yes floyd out here living his best life
you already know that's the truth he got
these guys to buy in how these dudes is
fighting on the aircraft carrier yo
anderson silva is a beast he's still a
beast to this day
that was a dope fight when anderson
silva let me see let me dismiss this
claim somebody
sent me some money um
showtime stuff
let me see let me see what y'all what
else let everybody else do what y'all
doing tonight y'all watching the fight
anybody watching a fight right now live
anybody saw the floyd fight
anderson silva need to fight these pole
brothers yeah for for sure
your showtime app is tripping right
this this is what i'm saying right now
my my the portal is something is is up
with the portal
whiskey night is a tennessee whiskey
night that's what's up
oh you're watching the fights on the
zone yeah i was gonna watch the fights
on the zone i mean
the zone app if if they have something
really good popping i don't like that
thing that they did with canelo
and they put canelo and bibble on a
pay-per-view after i paid that money to
watch it on the app you know um me
personally i don't i don't think that's
cool i think once i spend my money like
you claimed in the beginning they
claimed in the beginning that we'll be
able to get all their fights on this app
and all we had to do is pay for the year
so what happened we paid
and then
boom out of the blue we get canelo
versus uh they did it twice they did um
canelo or something
i think it was canelo with the
pay-per-view no i think bill and and
canelo was like the first one because
everything else that like the aj and all
that other stuff they gave it to us on
um
the whatchamacallit on app so this i
don't know man
i gotta keep refreshing my um
this app
yeah shelly let me know if your your
joint went in
eddie heard him bragging about no
pay-per-view but he pulls it on
pay-per-view facts
eddie here yeah eddie hearns is a crook
eddie hearns is a huge crook
i went i went to watch uh on espn plus
watch the um the ufc the holly holmes
fight
it was it was it was good
old girl was losing and
you know her corner went in on her and
then you know she pulled it out a little
bit
let me see this app
stay messing up man you got to keep
refreshing this app
it actually really sucks man i don't
know who did they team up with but
it's not cool with me
the floyd app was cool
the floyd app went straight through with
no problems
it was definitely um a good goal to
watch
you know if anybody even you know
watched the floyd app
my boy said he watched it with no
problem he he he was texting me i told
him i said i got to get some rest
before this show and i was like okay i'm
gonna knock this show out
that
we out here
waiting for this app down freeze your
shelly let me know if your app unfroze
yeah it's going in and out right now
right this
yours is going in and out i don't know
what's going on mine is not even um
what you're gonna call it refreshing
so i'm waiting for it to refresh but i
know they're not going to get into the
ring until probably like around 12
o'clock anyway
so
how i see um
benavidez versus uh lemieux lemuel
before he fought triple g and that was
probably man how long ago did he fight
triple g was that like five years ago or
four years ago before lemieux fought
triple g
he was his knockout artist everybody he
was fighting he it was happening and
then he fought triple g
triple g hit him with a coco on top of
the head
and that wasn't even i don't know it
wasn't even a match
and he made triple g into the monster
like the the the legend of triple g so
be honest with you i think the lemur
fight really secured that whole triple g
as a monster type of thing
and
ever since then it's just been like hit
or miss with lemieux
uh david benavidez
his biggest yeah it was four years ago
yeah okay see mac four years ago
um
he said uh espn got some uh boxing as
well right now yeah yeah espn right now
uh my espn i got um
the ufc joint uh fighting on right now
um
but it's it it's kind of crazy that
david benavidez he lost his joint on a
scale
his his weight man he that's when he had
to move up to 168.
i don't know
i just found him to look a little bit uh
less distant that's discipline
this fight right had these two dudes
like um lemieux and and benavidez
tell me man don't their bodies look soft
did anybody see the weigh-in
their bodies look soft to me it didn't
um how can i say like they didn't look
if anybody saw rolly ramirez uh
workout this week
rolly's
yo when they took his shirt off
i said i don't know about him and tank
i told my boy uh shout out queen yo i
told queen yo i might have to put a
hundred dollars on rolly
just in case
because i think it's paying 7-1 right
he lost his belt two times off of some
dumb stuff yeah
i want all that smoke
yeah yo rolly looks
ridiculous
now tank doesn't look tank look a little
soft in the middle man
sp i'm i'm telling you i saw the open
workout
and i'm looking at the middle i'm like
is he is he disrespecting this dude
rolly though
if you look at rolly's body
from then until now his arms right i
mean yeah yeah so t his arms is his arms
um tank arms look good i'm talking about
the gut
not gonna lie rolly looked
hyped this fight he rolley here he's
he's hyping his fight up
yo
rolly when i saw rolly's back
and then
they you know he turned around because
remember he took his shirt off and he
had his back to the camera
when he turned around rolling arms
always looked
decent
his arms look way better his chest looks
way better and his abs look on deck
he said i got you on the gut pull
it's really crazy yes ro rolly um
no lie is like tank's gut looks a little
bit soft
and rolly
rolly rolly got enough to get you to be
like man if this dude actually lands a
punch
if he actually has a punch what the hell
tank gonna do be honest with you like is
his tank gonna um
be able to take it it pulls and it's
take on
what's gonna happen i think that's the
biggest uh deciding factor
you know what
you're right you're right uh shelly
because uh
when he um when he said that tank is too
small for him
this is kind of true
tank is a smaller dude but tank is a
smaller dude when he fights everybody
and everybody has that same game plan
until tanks start ripping off them shots
and i think everybody started getting
gassed up off of um
isaac cruz
when uh he
you know fought tank
and
i i gave isaac probably like three
rounds that fight to be honest with you
and you got people acting like
isaac did so much yeah tank got his
power
rolly got power too
that's the
question is is it is it a big
uh
a good big guy versus
a a good little guy is tank great
is is is he good so
it
you know i'm i'm in between with it
he said isaac cruz beat tank
don't cat
man listen i would suggest you go back
and watch the fight man and then watch
it with an unbiased eye
then you know cc
see shots hitting shoulders
and sliding off arms and and see uh uh
the counter punching
uh because i think tank hurt his hand in
that fight so he went and it was his
primary hand so he went uh really
defensive for the rest of the fight
are you surprised
yo you know what
i ain't gonna i ain't gonna front cmac
i think
tank yeah tank our box screws that's the
fact
but i think tank was what like you said
was thrown off because he was remember
he was supposed to fight rolly that
fight
he trained for a bigger dude he trained
for a taller dude so
you know isaac you know was a late
replacement and in the fight and then he
gets into the fight
and he's the shorter dude so that's a
huge adjustment
that might be crazy vernon forrest
versus myog again remember that
yeah
yeah isaac was a a little bit uh
well you know isaac style is aggressive
he's an aggressive fighter you know
hold on
let me refresh this stream
man i'm sitting here
i really i really don't want to do
anything
around showtime pay-per-view
be honest with you man
because it is it's really disgusting
it's really disgusting i'm going in
between the apps
and the other time i had double paid by
mistake and had to wait
uh for the credit to hit my account
and
i think that's how they be getting their
numbers up by mistake
have you behind double paying and then
you double pay and they numbers go up
but your numbers your wallet go down
yeah that was a crazy fight
he said the boxer lost that night
[Laughter]
straight unorthodox form from my other
forest was confused in there
yo yeah rest in peace to vernon forest
anybody who knows um go check out vernon
forest
a hell of a fighter a hell of a fighter
lost he he lost his life to some
senseless crap um
and
you know we we we have precious
commodities in our boxes and we almost
all lost earl spence off for some you
know crap
you know some
so
could you imagine that no man hell no i
i that night i was like he's one of
earl's family members i was like oh hell
no please no
no no no nunez ferraro's fight
robbie reunite
yeah could be
arrow arrow was lucky he didn't have a
seat belt on
that's the only time i've ever heard if
um if he had a seat belt on he would
have died
because the fact that he didn't have a
seat belt on shot him
out the car when the car was flipping
it was like the the the first of the
second flip
earl flipped out the car
and the car just kept going but if he
was in the if he had a seatbelt on it
would have rolled up with him he would
have been crushed in the car
and and and
i don't i'm not an advocate advocate of
not having no seatbelt on but
that night earl if he had a seatbelt on
he wouldn't be here
and
man god forbid
i really like earl spence i think earl
spence
um
is
you can't say he's the marvin mark
the modern-day
uh haggler
because his style is not that like he's
a southpaw
uh he's he's a mike mccollum to me
right
yeah he's blessed not lucky facts facts
imax
facts
um
he he's like
a modern day
mike mccollum
because you know the body snatcher was
wicked
you know guardian angels was working
overtime for sure he had two that day
boy
but is not the modern day haggler
let's let's let's
let's let's stop that because bud is
is a box of puncher
right he just and the only reason why i
seem like you you would say that is
because
he switches from southport orthodox
right
um
i
i'm not i can't i can't go with him with
that because haggler was a hunker down
stay in front of your face
break you down type of dude
and
bud is not a hunker down stay in your
face type of dude butt is a boxer
puncher that switches from orthodox to
southpaw he's a savant in the ring and
when he gets you in trouble he goes in
there to get you out
um and he uses the the
the southpaw stance
to
[Music]
uh check out what's wrong with you
that's what he's in his defense and then
when he goes into his orthodox that's
when he's in his offense i think that's
a true flaw
in his character
as as you fight because you see when
he's having a hard time
he switches
and
it works you know here and there but
i mean it works for him the whole of his
whole career because he's never lost but
now i can't give him haggler haggler was
a beast like you know him and john the
beast mugabe that was a crazy fight
um
i do i dare say
he he's he reminds me of uh
of sugar ray
i mean
you know sugar ray didn't switch in
between
yeah blood switches substance not fluid
yeah
michael
is
i agree with the mike mccollum
comparison mike mccallum is
is more slick though
yeah but
so is so is earl
earl is a sl yo earl don't really be
getting hit that much unless he be
wanting to get hit that porta fight he
wanted to fight porter in the pocket he
wanted to stay in porter's pocket and
and and take it from him pause
um the danny fight
he stood in front of danny and he just
like broke danny down danny was scared
to throw that stupid uh blind left hook
and and he was afraid to throw it he got
to the point where his pops was like yo
come on throw some throw your hands
throw your hands
um
i think the the fact that he was ripping
him to the body
takes that away i
i
really want to say bud reminds me of
sugar ray to be honest with you like
when when bud gets dudes in trouble he
he he goes in for the kill
so
and that's what sugar rate remember
sugar ray had power
sugar ray had boxing
is he a smartest sugar ray
um
i think that's what separated sugar ray
from tommy
from um um
hands of stone uh
from
hagler
and uh a couple of other ones um
it was sugary smarts
you know so is is is bud as smart we i
don't ever think that bud can outmuscle
arrow
i think
bud
has to outsmart arrow
if he can get errol to fall into his
trap
of because you know what arrow does what
arrow does is remember when we said that
uh well not we when they said that uh
mikey had a high iq he went out there to
box mikey and when he fought mikey
what he did with mikey was he could have
knocked mikey out
he held mikey up that whole fight and
just continued to batter mikey
throughout the whole fight right
and that's when i knew he was a
malicious fighter because he could have
took mikey out of there and every time
he had mikey in the corner or whatever
he got off the gas
so
if if
bud can get
arrow to follow him
and fight uh buds fight
bud might be the smarter fight if if bug
could be excuse me if buck could beat a
smarter fighter
he might be able to beat arrow but
earl's work rate
earl's jab earl's body attack and earl's
work rate with his power and his ability
to break you down
and hit hit one specific part and keep
breaking that part down so it doesn't
work anymore
that can really
you know work to buds detriment and
remember the advantage of southpaw is
not there no more because the south pole
versus southpaw right so if he goes to
orthodox that's playing into earl's
hands so bud has to fight in a defensive
form the whole night long right
hmm
i i don't know man that fight
is is so much you said sugar ray fought
inside out
of emotion like the first duran would
that never happen with but yeah the
truth
yeah
yeah
button spencer is gonna be a technical
fight yeah it's gonna be a technical
fight on
how how far um whatchamacallit pushes it
bud pushes it because bud is gonna push
that fight right um but i mean um earl's
gonna push that fight but is bud gonna
sit there
and uh take it pause is bug gonna move
to where
he has to um
eliminate this guy this this this app is
sick man
yo uh
shelly tell me what your app is doing
because is your app frozen because my
app is frozen
what's funny is my dubai app is still uh
rocking with floyd
this is stupid this is absolutely stupid
because my boy sent me his link so that
link is actually
still
available
i think they're still counting money in
dubai
messing with floyd
let me see
pushing up
that's why you got to have at least two
to three pcs going at one time
let me see
shelly what's up xbox is doing fine
right now
all right
so you watching it through the x-mas
ain't got my xbox on this right here
but we'll push the fight spencer just
jab and control distance until bud
pushes the pace
you think bud is just gonna um
is is bug gonna be
am i wrong here because i thought portal
was winning that fight um if you go
through it objectively right and you
watch the fight with portal versus butt
i thought
uh
um porter was winning the fight or the
fight was even at that point in time
even bud's corner
thought that uh porter was winning the
fight and told butt in that round yo
he's winning he was like what how and
then that's when he went and he turned
it up
um
i don't know
my app ain't working at all but
this is ridiculous this is
this is absolutely ridiculous man let me
see if i refresh my joint
let me see
let me see
refresh i'll refresh my whole joint i
don't care
then
let me start my joint
wait a second
why did wow
do not tell me that
do not tell me that
let me see okay so now it's flipping let
me see
no okay my there goes my sports yeah
baby
all right
let's see let's see
dude i gotta call customer service
the devil be busy as hell boy
that's what i get for not having
the combat talk upstairs inside
uh the main room main room is being
worked on right now so it's almost
finished as soon as that main room is
finished we good money
let me see where we at oh yeah
and i should have did ufc talk tonight
i'm going to do a whole ufc talk
on that soon
blessings brother blessings always good
yeah spence doesn't have a problem with
boxing or initiating
oh it's a server issue
okay
okay
thank you
because i'm thinking i'm bugging out
like
i don't know what the hell is going on
i'm thinking it's just me
and this is stupid man
this is absolutely stupid remember um yo
so last week i thought i was going to be
on vacation this week
no i'm on vacation next week i'm on
vacation actually with the tank rolly
fight
so
i'm actually going to get a chance to
see uh the tank rolly fight on uh a nice
sunny beach with my feet up
yo you can't sign in and your bill is
paid right
see
it
it's it's i don't know i don't i don't
know what's up man showtime has been
dropping a ball lately i don't know what
the hell is going on so hopefully um
everything rectifies itself
um benavidez is not in the ring yet
how how do i see this fight going with
benavidez versus lemieux
um i think there's a is another uh get
by fight for benavidez until he can
either get charlo in the ring or
somebody of world of note
i think this is the biggest name
that uh
he can get
that's not um
like uh you know charlo or
or um
this guy canelo
ah
benavidez seems to be the odd man out
always
right he's uh
too tall
too big pulse
and
dudes is like i rather just avoid them
because the money's not there you know
benavidez is not an attractive
um
name to to to fight right so i guess the
name once once the name ain't there then
that's what the issues is and and they
need that money
so
i don't know man um this fight is a good
fight for him
if he knocks out lemieux in spectacular
fashion does he go after triple g
you know what i never heard i never
heard
benavidez call out triple g
anybody ever heard of benavidez call out
triple g's let me know because i've
never heard
benavidez
called triple g out and want to fight
triple g
and i got i got to see that because i
know he sits there and he talks about
the charlo one of the charles he talks
about um
jamal
i'll fight jamal i'll fight jamal like
he has a problem with jamal
makes no sense but um he's always
calling out jamal
yo now that jamel
is unified champion
he goes up his brother goes up his
brother goes up to 168
and battles for
the belt up there
demetrius andrade is available i heard
that uh benavidez is talking about
fighting androti
after this fight
that's weird that might happen but you
but you have jamal go up to 168 you have
jemele go up to 160 and and try to
gather the bells there and then
after spence fights bud
win lose a draw
he goes up to
uh 154 to battle for those belts up
there
147
boots keith thurman and these guys stay
down there fighting for those belts
there
excuse me
i got i got i got boots
uh cleaning up that division but i would
love to see uh boots versus um
uh uh this guy uh uh um
thurman
if i can get boots versus thurman
oh my god and they talking about that
well
what you put see matt you pulled that
out of there pause let me see andre
charlo plant benevitas all need to fight
each other and stop waiting to get the
canelo check
that's easy to say shello shelly um
when when you have somebody in the
division that you see that makes the
most money and he you can
you see deficiencies in them and you can
take the deficiency away
you can fight him
wouldn't you go after that i mean i
would
let me let me see what c-max said
andrade has been active
no
once andrade uh got offered the zone
because remember he's offered his own so
i guess he is a free agent i don't know
if he went to the bbc
yes yes sp thurman versus ennis um
they talking about that being a
pay-per-view
and i think that's thurman's only way
of getting his name in the conversation
is he would he be catching boots at the
right time like too young too early not
ready enough as for for thurman because
you know young keith thurman and
remember i told dudes boots reminds me
of keith thurman a lot
would that be like the old replacing the
new
or
with the old you know stand up because
thurman's still got a little crack in
that back you know
you i don't know man
the only thing the only difference is
thurman cannot take a body shot to save
his life
and i think boots
only
thought process would be to go to
uh thurman's body i mean we saw thurman
get dropped by manny by um
or whatchamacallit by a punch to the jaw
but he went down he got up you know
you know thurman i think thurman takes a
good shot to the jaw
but his body shots is it's absolutely
horrible i don't i don't think he takes
a good body shot to save his life and
that's why he avoided earl for all those
years like
because we know earl just goes straight
to the body
let me see
again let's refresh this
this crappy app
let's see what's going on man
showtime
yo i know benavidez is probably upset
because he probably got his peoples
rolling his app
and if they can't get their money's
worth
man listen
see
this is this is this is no good
i used to do it with hulu and on my xbox
on my xbox i would do hulu and have show
time through my xbox
let me see let me see let me see
that's andrade ford and this
thurman didn't see that punch for manny
no he didn't see that punch with manny
hey king what's up stop about to show
you some of thank you say thank you uh
kaiju what's going on brother
rich boy what's up
i think bud really don't want to fight
arrow so he's acting like spence
lowballing but i actually intentionally
priced himself out to fight
rich
boy
he has a belt that
he has to fight
i don't care what he wants to do
the dog in him is going to have him
fight i don't i don't care what he wants
to do
um i this is the highest this earl is
the biggest strongest dude that he's
going to fight
um the biggest strongest most technical
dude uh i think it's a 50 50 fight to be
honest with you in my opinion had this
earl never had the car accident
i would have said that it was probably
75 25 uh earl
earl after the car accident i would say
50 50 but i know you're gonna say earl
looks better after the car accident than
he did before then but
little things
will pull up we don't know the little
things that's happening with earl at all
we don't know the little things right we
do know about the teeth and the stuff
like that in the face and you know he
had to mend
um we do know about some of you know
the knicks in here but you know
psychologically
what what what what is it right so
again i say 50 50. to be honest with you
both these guys keep themselves in
relative good shape so i i don't know
man to be honest with you
let me see um
probably why they're having issues
let's see
remember thurman tell telling you to
don't duck me son don't duck me son
when i'm coming at you don't duck me son
when i'm coming your way that's that's
when thurman was on his
job like
one that's when he was yelling out one
time like he
he sounded like deontay wilder with bomb
squad
that's when he was like don't duck me
stun when that that's what he was
telling dudes i'm coming for those belts
he he fought his contemporaries man he
and
[Music]
you know
he knew both of his contemporaries
had limitations danny had a limitation
danny danny had slow feed he run he
reminded me of my cousin trinner that um
but trinidad has more technical boxer
one two both hands go and that left hook
off that joint is crazy uh he
trinidad was a lot more active than
danny danny's a a counter puncher
box a counter puncher a strong
a strong puncher
he knew danny had slow feet so all he
had to do was just move around danny and
fight danny thurman did and he can he
can beat danny um porter
porter to me always look like a football
player
boxing right an athlete boxing so
uh keith wins in that equation to me
nice fight but kiev is supposed to win
in that equation so i think keith had a
level of confidence going into those
fights
i don't think he had that level of
confidence if he had to fight earl so
that's why that fight never happened
when keith was champion and errol wanted
to fight him so
and earl had to go and go get the belts
to to actually make these guys uh get in
line and fight them
let me see
don't talk me son
thurman messed up his career by
being inactive
and those silk sheets nah you know what
what what happened kermit um
when thurman got married
that's when he like settled
like you got to look at what a fighter
is like like you know his trainer died
you know his pop situation all that
other stuff like where he came from then
he finally got a family got his wife
you know and that stuff started
happening
he took a breath
this fight game is brutal there's no
breathing in between
i don't know how floyd mayweather was
able to have as many women even floyd
never got married
as many women as he had
as many kids as he had
still been active in their life
and still
been that dude
right we seen canelo
try that whole situation and had to fall
off floyd never has the fl falloff right
so thurman
once he took a break
his body started catching up to him so
he said well you know let me take let me
fix some stuff up and you know get the
surgery and get the stat and the third
done and still stay active in this world
and then he gets into the fights with
with manny pacquiao and he loses that
fight a fight technically if he never
took the time off he's supposed to beat
manny he's supposed to do what ugas did
but he
he didn't have that day it wasn't there
let me see
yeah when he knocked out uh diego travis
it was a yeah it was a big deal back
then it was definitely a big deal back
then a a hell of a big deal
oh man they better not fold my evening i
swear to god man
they're better enough for my evening
because
this will definitely piss me off
this would definitely piss me off more
than you know guys trust me
trust me because i definitely
do not want to go upstairs and watch it
because
then you know because i just do it on my
hulu app but my hulu app
and my account and my stuff is not here
this is stupid as hell man
watch they do some more 11 o'clock hey
guys hey guys
anybody watch the podcast hey guys
all right here we go
what's going on
no
this is y'all doing it disgusting to me
this is this is not a thing
can't be can't be
all right here we go about time jesus
crackers with cheese
all right nunez versus ferrero all right
here we go
show time you suck
you suck show time
i want my money back showtime this is
out i'm beholding the showtime this is
actually disgusting man
all right so we in live let's get it
let's get it all right share it out
right now so what we got right now we
got nunez versus ferro 7th round right
now and um
see
if i'm looking at body posture right now
it looks like uh ferro
is uh
is uh leading in the fight to be honest
with you nunes can't pull the trigger
he's trying to
shoot his southpaw jab
let me see
no nunez is orthodox nunes has forever
on the corner
pushing them in in the corner
nothing nothing nothing too much
oh
nunes called fierro with a left hook
oh nice shots
they look well matched um to be honest
with you the ppc puts together good
cards
they they look well matched right now so
the pvc actually puts together cards
that makes sense
which stylistically like you never
really get stinkers i think the zone has
a problem with actually match making
usually they probably match names and
don't match styles
oh oh thank you evil monk what's going
on much love brother
yeah this ain't sunday you don't gotta
do the super chats like that boy the boy
reading the boy reading your situation
a boy reading it
so you know i mean super chats is
welcome you know super likes and all
that stuff and oh anybody just coming in
right now drinking choice tonight is uh
margherita's watermelon margaritas fresh
squeezed watermelon
yes yes evening
will screen what's going on your screen
i haven't been on
playing um destiny in a minute and i
need you to help me get through this
raid i got to do this raid so
yeah the zone has horrible undercards
oh pharrell almost got dropped twice
yeah
that
young young young guys young guys right
now head butt a head butt in the middle
of the ring
uh nunes quarter head bunt
uh so ferrero luna's caught him with uh
a left to the body
forever um ferrero looks
the fresher of the two
all right so nunes is uh jabbing
and uh you have uh ferrero
there's a southpaw
there's it's
they're boxing in the center of the ring
nothing's really exchanged in round
eight you expect to be landing telling
shots
at this point in the fight i mean uh
punches that actually uh tell the judges
what's going on i see a lot of shoulder
hitting
um
a lot of see
uh nunez is trying to catch uh i mean
pharaoh's trying to catch nunes coming
in nunes hops in with shots
and he boxes with his hands at his waist
uh
that gives an inviting target but if you
not defensively sound or if you're not
athletically uh
endowed you might catch a shot so i
think uh nunes is more of a nice uh uh i
mean ferrero is more of a defensive
fighter this is the first uh time i'm
watching both of these fighters
and i love the fact that you know um pvc
showcases a lot of their fighters on
cards that have good main events so you
get a chance to see a lot of the up and
coming fighters
on the cards people to endear yourself
to if you're getting into boxing
so really they're not really doing too
much they don't
excuse me a lot of posturing in the
middle of the ring
um you can tell the level of skill they
have to upgrade their level of skill
because okay at this point in time
you're not supposed to be it's tight
they're falling in with their heads
falling in together
uh punches are being exchanged but these
punches are sloppy punches nothing good
nothing that you really can score so
really if you if you're a scoring judge
you're going to see uh head snapping
back
and and anything clear that you can see
with it so there's a lot of fainting in
the middle of the ring a lot of air jabs
a lot of body shots
nothing too much they're both standing
in the middle of the ring posturing
fainting trying to faint the next one
out of position nothing is really being
thrown
to be honest with you nothing of note
you know they they one lands one shot
another lands a shot
nothing fantastic you see the level of
uh of of technical powers in the main
event
change very quickly see the round is
over nothing nothing of note um and i
would be upset because technically
you're supposed to teach your fighter
see
you see if you're watching right um
ferrero had nunes around the side of his
head nunes was coming up with a punch
under the body missed and didn't hit
anything
you know both of them land in both shots
see they're falling in throwing shots
nothing nothing of note
let me see let me see what's going on
this one has horrible new season coming
up
so you know you get it
i might hold off
well on the new season to be honest with
you i have a lot of stuff that i'm
playing um destiny hasn't yanked me back
in
and they better
you know eldon ring right now it's kind
of crazy and i've been playing this
fortnight fortnight but wow once they
put that no build
fortnite put the no build inside it was
crazy
let me see
do you think we ever get tank versus
shaquille stevens
if tank gets past rolly
rich boy we we acting like rolly don't
got that punches chance
rolly rolls in there with that coco
tasso and him up top his head
you know
what happens then
all right so nunes is landing a couple
of shots um
and then
you know uh ferrero uh tightened up his
defense and now he's walking and it's
too much posturing too much you know
uh
i i don't like that i like i like
fighters that actually do work punch
that actually matter
let me see
floyd exhibition was pretty
entertaining i got to go watch that to
be honest with you uh who said that
dookie kicks what's up i i definitely
hate dookie kicks that's crazy
uh let me see let's be he's been like
this the whole fight except ferrero
getting caught
show me your bill facts
dudes punching people low let me see
fontuna with no builders and your
fortnight with no builders what's up
yeah
that fortnight and you ain't got to
worry about somebody throwing up a wall
and building all to the sky
and nah nah crank warm up what my son
said cranking some 90s you ain't gotta
worry about that i'm gonna get you and i
got i said i sent my son a couple of um
a couple of clips when i was coming in i
was getting my uh
my chicken dinners what they're coming
in first place uh royal victory royale
chicken dinner
pub g chicken dinner i want my chicken
dinner
yeah holly holm's lost i was watching i
was watching that holly holm's look
listen
they went to the corner and told old
girl you know what the corner told now
how long's going to the other girl to go
they told her yo
did you come here to fight or did you
come here to watch her are you a fan of
this girl are you about to get in here
and mix it up
and she did the butt she did the butt
like when you know when they told bud
that he was losing to porter
and he and he went in there
he turned up on boy
yo she did the same joy
i think that's gonna be uh the new thing
your fighter is losing or your fight is
not giving this all you gonna go there
see yo me
your kids is watching let me call your
kids and tell them how you performing
that's dope
that's dude that's dope
this fight is absolutely
not what what you expect from young
fighters what you expect from young
fighters is go get it and stop trying to
protect that oh
you know ferrero is fighting defensive
nunes is
uh trying to get him but they they're
they're all air jabbing
let me tell you a secret about fighters
that don't really want to fight when
they hear that their bell
and and they're tapping on the mat one
two three four yo
that's when they turn up like they
fighting ah because they know they're
about to stop the you'll start to fight
you go to your corner you can go sit
down
i don't like fighters like that i like
when the rounds start they go at you
and they don't care about that bell i
like dudes that keep fighting until the
referee breaks them up belgium go off
but i ain't hear it man i'm trying to
kill you
that's what i like let me see holly
holm's like 66 years old she's [ __ ] she
should retire
oh yeah
oh my career
yo sp you are dead wrong for that
hey what up king
and chad hope y'all having a great night
like those
yo
mr itchy yes yes what's going on holly
holmes
holly holm's body was not fighting that
night yeah this is true
she said i like y'all like your style
xbox gotta give us hellblade 2 or
something to make up for the
delays hell i'll settle for golden eye
rich boy
they don't owe us a damn thing let's
keep it a buck anybody that's here
let's stop you know um
i heard these dudes talking about all
the delays is hurting the end of the
year
we don't know actually
listen okay so listen let me act like i
don't know a lot of stuff right
um
we don't know what they're showing after
june
right so what people are getting all
gassed up about is that the playstation
has all this good uh information in the
early part of the year they should have
good information early part of the year
playstation is a front loaded company
that gets the mind share for the
beginning of the year and try to ride
through to the end of the year through
the holiday season and i think it has
something to do with the philosophies we
in the western part of the world we tend
to look at the holiday season as the
last part of the year and go harder than
to get your your buying power in the
eastern part of the year where you know
christmas really isn't the celebrated
brand and stuff like that
they usually front load then the
beginning of the year
you have gran turismo and you have
forbidden west you're going to get some
other stuff
there's this uh dropping as far as dlc
free stuff for them
then they drop any stuff in june with
their service so this seems like a lot
of good information i mean as a gamer
you're supposed to be very happy about
what's going on delays is always good
especially when it's a game that you
don't want to come out broken so that
game doesn't come out good it doesn't
come out it's not worth coming out right
now don't act like you want a game so
bad and if it's in a bad state that it's
a good thing no let that game get cooked
let it get done because if it launches
terrible cyberpunk i purchased the game
right it's not a game pass i said that
but i said i get it after the patch i
was hoping that it'd get the game pass
with the patch or whatever
you know maybe they looked at it and
didn't fit inside their repertoire
yeah this fight is almost over and it's
a sloppy nasty fight nothing nothing i
care about to be honest with you none of
these fighters stood out to me and
showed me anything so um i honestly
expect
um
star
2023 and
you don't want to hear this 2023 might
start off microsoft finally for the
first time
uh getting the first half of the year
and also getting the second half of the
year microsoft is a second half of the
year company and if they can release um
and this is the reason why you you get
bethesda you get activision uh and these
companies uh because you can start front
loading the first half of the year and
get in the middle of the year and the
end of the year so that's what they're
looking to do
um
as long as the showcase file i'd be
happy
i'm you still playing yes i'm still
playing elden ring toe and i ended it yo
first of all i didn't even know i was
playing the fight in the last boss to be
honest with you and then uh when it
ended i was like what the hell then
because i got the ready ending and
because i like her i like she was so
cute and she sat there because and and
i said yeah i'll follow her and i wanted
to do her stuff but um
listen guys we we we definitely don't
don't go into these spaces with these
losers talking about all this uh civil
war stuff
there's no civil war we don't work at
microsoft we don't work at sony and
what's really weird
those people that work in microsoft and
work at sony don't hate each other
it's kind of crazy right
we're the only idiots outside in the
streets talking about there's a war
outside going on
no it isn't
it's games
let me see live on i'm still playing
ellen i can only play while my wife's
while my wife's shows aren't on y'all
feel you i fail you
yo so what you do is you get a little
man and you get the screen
boom
that just happened
or you take your phone and make sure
that you get a big enough phone that you
put the uh the little bars on the end
and you get the the razer kishi
and get your game on son
get your game on son
don't you duck me son
am i saying xbox got games i never said
they left
you know um i mean listen dudes dudes
dudes head that i joke a lot i joke a
lot right oh i tease the playstation
dudes and yeah
and now my xbox dude whatever um
they all got they did the deficiencies
what is x what is the playstation gonna
drop for the second half for the year
we'll figure it out once the games um
stack comes through and we get a chance
to see what's happening with the summer
games fest yo jeff keagley actually
messed stuff up to be honest with you
because dude just holding information
for the summer game fest nintendo's the
only one that's operating outside of
this box
people is not holding them accountable
to anything they drop whenever they want
however they want and give you what they
want on their timeline so you know come
on but back to these fights what's going
on
that's right he can use the tablet with
a controller telemitchie
yo
i'ma say this
she has a lot of shows
i'ma say this um
shelly
i'm not a souls fan
play that game
you know i i'm gonna get that
playstation uh
you know uh network joint in june i'm
gonna get the the top tail one i'm about
a year joint even though i know it's
worth 8 bucks whatever who cares i don't
i don't care about that i saw a couple
of things in there like days gone that i
didn't purchase that i would like to
play um i saw a couple of stuff that was
in there that i want to play so i'm
gonna play it i'm gonna do it i don't
care my playstation has dust on it and
um hopefully
it
that that'd get me playing and i might
just run out and just go get my son a
playstation five
you know um
if if they do game sharing and we can
share accounts i'll get him a
playstation five and
we're share libraries i'll talk to attic
and see if they do that i mean so
it's it's gonna be worth it you know and
and and the family uh stuff for xbox
with the game pass man
these dudes is behind because of kovac
man
you know i said none yet for game pass
this year
what you mean you ain't got nothing yet
for game pass have you been inside game
but man if you don't get off my timeline
you see listen
how many games are you gonna finish and
how many games you're gonna get done
just go outside game pass get something
done in there let me see starfield red
four was delayed but not canceled i
understand some frustration man drop two
20 22 l ring is possible
yeah eldering is game of the generation
i don't care what nobody say
he said they got pornhub you're
ridiculous
flowers this year because after this yes
the
sniper elite i feel like can you do it
for the game sharon's kind of weird to
set up
it is yo somebody got to walk me through
it i'm going to look at a tutorial on it
all right we got 29 people we got 41
likes that's crazy got 31. all right so
i guess the main event is next hopefully
thank god please i own a handheld pc
caller you know which is a stream day
camp steroids it runs gaming services
and cooling gamepl
yo
dookie
floyd
puts that work
on any of these young dudes floyd has
kept his body in such phenomenal shape
and he's been such a gym rat he has been
such a um
locked into his hobby his habit
his career
that it's hard to get out of him
and and floyd is financially
uh in a different position
we got to go to work
i got to get up i don't care what
business i own i don't care what i do i
gotta get up and i gotta go to work and
i gotta grind
um floyd has to grind too but he's
grinding at and his pay is different and
but he's doing something that he's
actually in love with he's been in love
with since a child if floyd didn't love
it trust me any fighter that you've seen
after they retired after they go away
they blow up and wait mike tyson
ballooned in weight then he became a
vegan went down away you know after he
got with his wife and he started getting
stable
and we have uh david lemieux inside his
uh his his dressing room
looking pretty decent he looks soft
around the middle i told you guys anyway
uh you gotta ask yourself this question
is david lemieux just there for the
check
um
hopefully not his body doesn't look um
as strong in his tight paws when he
fought
um
triple g
when david lemieux fought triple g he
was stronger he looked stronger his
muscles looked better
um
and i i thought
that he had a shot
to doing something see these they're
showing a couple of clips of david
lemieux right now
and
i i hope i hope he gives a hell of a
counter herself right yeah his left [ __ ]
he just
sniffs somebody out right there his left
hook is pretty decent but again that's
against
mediocre
to subpar opponents if if if you're
telling david lemieux to to step up um
like they're showing when he fought
triple g and
see triple g
right hand was really ridiculous and
i i
i'm gonna be honest with you
i haven't seen david step up
so david versus david david versus david
benavites versus lemieux
um
we already know right now that uh
benevites is the betting favorite
um
[Music]
it's not like lemieux is
uh a chump
he's a former champion
but lemieux is also
uh is he also ran you know um
what
years from now would anybody be talking
about his name in the pantheons of um
great 168 is right
and and these are the questions that we
ask ourselves
i think this is my wife
oh cueno
yo quanyo if you're watching hold on let
me let me put it in the chat
hold on let me um
put the fight in the chat coin yo yeah
yeah um
yes
let me see
i'm off twitter until i ended him off
let me tell them go to youtube girl
that's my dude that i talk to that's my
vegas guy um he's my uh my my cali
family we talk fights all the time
um we're always in the background like
twitter you know talking to each other
talking to the fights i'm getting a a a
face shoot done he getting a pedicure
so we're talking he just had a birthday
too let me see
let me see what's going on
cole main event is next oh man y'all
went wild
y'all went wild all right bb stop
playing some of those smaller games
that's right king david jaffe is saying
if god of war ragnarok comes out this
year it'll take game of the year for
sure
maybe
i don't care god of war ragnarok is not
gonna be um eldering i don't i don't
care
in my opinion
i don't care if starfield would have
came out it wasn't going to be elder
ring in my opinion
you have to figure out what captivates
you i mean as as you as a gamer you know
let me see uh tyson needs to get back in
there with all the energy he's still got
it tyson is high 900 of the time
forget that
tyson is good for doing exhibitions
capitalizing on his name and get that
money
floyd was letting his hands go it was
very entertaining to see he look well
rested
um remember floyd suffered from um
brittle hands so him letting his hands
go right now is it's not a shock and the
fact that um
floyd
is doing exhibitions he's going to be a
little bit more free
than normal you know
let me see
excuse
me a few people get to do what they love
and get well paid for it
he said i hate my job and the pay is
little yo kermit
i'ma tell you this
i don't know
i don't know what you do
i'ma tell you in this life before it's
too late
go try to make yourself happy
the worst thing in the world is trying
to get out of your bed for a job that
you don't want to get up for
or
you hop out your bed for a job that you
love
you know um i had to make that choice
very early on with my kids
and um
i chose what made me happy
and i'm very happy you greet people with
a smile every day
you know and it's not really about the
pace sometimes it's really about how you
feel about the work that you're doing i
was getting paid really good money
at uh
but that had to do with uh exterminating
uh
certain kind of uh like lab animals
right so okay so they do experiments and
then after that the the time is over
those lab animals have to be euthanized
in a humane manner
but
when you start to become one with nature
you start to understand things and know
that animals and stuff have souls
anytime that you have to
do stuff like that trust me on god it
weighs on your soul hated that job pay
was fantastic had to get up out of there
couldn't do it no more
i don't know
yes lemieux looks soft at 168 you're
right
you're right tyson's brilliant he
stopped fighting and started his own
marijuana business no tyson has
brilliant people around him that
monetizes his name
rich boy thank you so much for the 10
super chat i appreciate the content you
bring
to boxing and the gaming community thank
you so much i appreciate it um listen i
got the statue stuff coming i got to sit
down and talk with graphic guard on on
putting the bells and whistles on this
show he's he's wrapping up all the stuff
that we're doing with kos we like it
like at an impasse i want the intro to
be uh as as perfect as the intro is for
this show i think the intro for um
combat talk with the king
uh with dallas spitting those bars
with the vintage fights uh
it all flows
right
and that's what i want to give you guys
i want to give y'all guys that content
that actually flows an identity of me
those fights that you see
watched all those fights excuse me
um
if you listen to my pantheon of uh old
fighters and stuff that i do love
uh you you get that you get that from me
all right cole man event is coming up yo
tell me boy oh boy don't look like tiger
woods son
hey yo he look like tiger hey
he y'all this i
i'm not racist i'm black so don't play
with me
yo
look like tiger with someone but this
dude look like lurch with boxing gloves
on god man coda look like lurks gomez
look like tiger wood sun we got tiger
wood sun versus lurch
round one this is about to be a bond
burner
oh my god all right so we come out right
now all right let's see
now lurch looking nasty
large look like he's fighting in the you
know he got mma shots on ledge got on
the tighter shorts
oh man gomez tried to hit him in the
head with the coco tasso came over the
top with it
oh
lurch ain't playing alerts got the nasty
awkwards he got
[Laughter]
yo
alerts right now look crazy coda no
disrespect man he look
wow
bonkers
so tiger wood son is up on him that's
gomez right so lurch out there with the
with the with the jab
and then descent to the ring he has the
tightest
um pause he has the tightest shorts that
they had to give him
yo
tiger with son caught him with the right
hand that's right young tiger young
tiger
young tiger's stalking he trying to land
that right hand over the top
[Laughter]
yo
my money on young tiger son
oh yo lurch look like he in the in in
the fight of his life right now young
tiger trying to get a hole in one on god
he outside right
yo
i'm not gonna lie i like this kid i love
gomez i this is this is how you fight
this is how you fight shout out to young
tiger young gomez out here in the
building yeah yeah yo they don't want to
touch gloves
yo
so
it looks like a uh
a gomez that has the animation like oh
oh they just caught each other young
gomez caught him with that right hand yo
this is a dope first round for the cold
main event i am not gonna lie they got
me off my deem so much that this is the
first time i'm seeing young gomez get
busy with his joints right all right so
young gomez and i keep calling young
girls
he goes great body shot great right hand
yo so he has coda in the corner and he's
throwing punches to the body to the top
of the head and koda looks like an
animation on a fighter
he is crazy
it's hard to explain he's pulling up his
trunks with his boxing gloves like he
got fingers this is nuts if you try to
pull him up in the ring you really can't
this is kind of crazy
um oh man yo
gomez is a definitely good uh fighter to
watch i really like him win lose a draw
i really like his energy that he brings
in here um his stance his defense looks
pretty decent his right hand his
his ability to throw shots he's trying
to land shots he landed an uppercut
against the rope on coda these dudes are
fighting they fight until the bell is
over this is what i was talking about
that's what i'm talking about not that
not that sloppy mess that was the last
round i mean
the last uh last um the last fight
i'm talking about
this is what i'm talking about the
ability to want to mix it up the ability
to go in and let the ref break you up
when you are done with the round that's
what i'm talking about
he said young lurch is wild that's right
i'm talking to dave
yo
this is kind of crazy
yo what was that do what was why was he
touching his butt like that did you see
uh uh young lords touching his butt it's
crazy
all right young tigers back into the
center
yo
he somebody told him how a fighter is
supposed to perform and this kid is dope
he is out here i gotta check out his
record um
i was only paying attention to the main
event to be honest with you because i
didn't notice anybody of note that i
knew before
and
like yo yeah king professional fan
what's up
um
but gomez looks like a name that you're
going to take note from buck but
[Music]
oh man young tiger hit him with a short
uppercut on a break
yo this guy keeps pulling up his shorts
and he got the tightest shorts in the
building what are you pulling up my guy
you got on panties come on not not
panties underwear my bad underwear he
has on underwear i'm talking about
briefs i'm talking about super rules
under roots oh man he's going over the
top he's going to the to the side of his
head
i am not going to lie gomez is giving a
hundred percent of his self hit same
thing with carter but cody's just being
funny to me to be honest with you no
disrespect anytime you get in the ring
you're showing just your true self
you're showing who you are inside and
out so you know both true selves is here
but
this boy gomez is a monster to me
look at him but code is throwing punches
inside all right so they they let me
give you an accurate description right
now
uh
uh
gomez is stalking koda koda is uh his
back's up against the ropes gomez is
ripping shots to the body and over the
top gomez is trying to fight all the
ropes and go to his body to take some of
his energy off of uh
gomez
koda is slipping some punches while up
against the ropes gomez is pushing him
back up against the ropes going straight
to his body
his left to the body and his right hand
is really good koda ripping shots up the
middle so
if he can uh withstand
gomez's a barrage of punches
this stands to be a a test of attrition
to be honest with you
um
so again gomez has koda in the corner
but koda is uh his awkward styles allows
him to fight off the ropes and he's not
trying to get away he's trying to keep
gomez close to him
and he's letting the ref break it up
he's he's he's not um you know
waiting for uh something to happen he's
they're fighting until the ref breaks
them up so they're going back to the
corner right now right now is a little
bit of posturing but um again
wow
gomez just caught him with a short right
hand inside these right hands from gomez
a half step back doesn't smother his
work
gomez um
fights how you want your fighter to
fight
excuse me he doesn't smother his work he
knows his distance he knows his distance
very well he knows himself but the same
thing with coda coder knows himself too
so he knows that he's at a disadvantage
probably speed and power wise against uh
gomez so what he does look at that he
got a smile like young tiger woods he is
smiling he's engaging he's i really like
this kid i really like gomez i really
like this kid this kid looks really good
right here
let me see lurge sneaky awkward punches
this is true
this is true this is definitely true 100
yo and he's not even breathing koto is
sitting in the corner
not even breathing hard um
gomez
uh
had you know breathing a little bit but
he's excited you know you understand
like you know when you take your kids to
the park to go do something and your kid
just run off yeah that's what he looks
like right now he's running off to the
ring to go handle his business
round three
then the middle of the ring all right so
uh you have uh
coda throwing a one two but he drags his
uh
his trail foot over when he throws the
the right hand and that's never good
because you lose your um
your power off your pivot he moves his
his back foot
he looks like a a tie fighter like um
not not star wars tie fighter uh uh um
indonesian silence thai boxing fighter
so
yeah he's he's very awkward have anybody
ever seen a korean zombie inside uh mma
that's how that's what he looks like as
far as styling look
all right so um
young tiger woods out here gomez is uh
pressuring him without throwing oh my
god hit him with a short left hook
inside uh koto fell back against the
ropes he wasn't expected oh he threw
koda to the floor he threw koda to the
floor with a judo move
koda was trying to hold him he threw him
to the floor with the judo move he
caught him with that short left hook and
boo
yakkasha that boy went back like oh my
god he got dynamite in them sticks
that's right young tiger woods out here
trying to get a birdie let's get it
on deck right now
yo i am not gonna lie
young tiger looks great gomez now he's
feeling it he's getting a little bounce
to his step he's stalking him he's
talking go messi because he knows he has
him in trouble he's reaching with the
jab and he
his his punch selection is beautiful he
he threw an uppercut
uh left hook and it missed but his punch
selection is good gomez punches from
either stance he's moving he's switching
stance he switched to southpaw right now
caught up i mean uh not gomez cotto uh
and
trying to avoid some of these shots
and he keeps pulling up his short tighty
weight he's bad it's ridiculous
um so he's in a southpaw stance right
now oh no he went back to orthodox
all right so
he's trying oh my god
he hit him again with a short left hook
trying to get him off him all right here
we go boom oh boy this dude is joe this
gomez dude is
nasty
i definitely gonna check for him he they
picked a good one pbc picked a good one
to have as a co-main event
good stylistically uh encoder i don't
know so right now he has him in the
corner gomez does um kota fort fights
out of the corner
gomez is trying showing a different side
of him right so he's into the philly
crab shell style hands crossed this way
as he's blocking and he's throwing his
left hook his left hook is his prominent
punch but his right hand is his money
punch as you can see that he tries to
land all the time so he goes right back
to the body oh oh the referee got
punched in the face everybody can get
these hands these hands is available for
everyone
e for everyone
e
that's the ref faces in the game
yo the ref tried to step in on the break
he caught that swam me to the chimney
yo they just got they just watching the
rough yo the camera has just been on the
rough cuz the rough quarter yo he caught
a good left hook to the chin
the ref got a chin right
see my ref got a chin
[Laughter]
yo
i am not gonna front young tiger woods
is out here flipping those
tiger woods out
crazy yo this this is this made up this
morning made up for that last round that
last fight
oh let's go let's go
all right all right so
you're a rough guy pull him in the
corner man cut it out man when i said
break break don't be punching me in my
face
round four
oh he caught him again young young tiger
cotto again
oh man
here we go
who's the chick looking like a vampire
in the third row
you see the with the pink here look kind
of crazy scary can't come with me
outside like that
all right let's go
all right so young tigers stalking them
your boys in southport stands yeah yeah
yeah yeah getting that shelf pull on
coda don't care coda like oh
get away from me
excuse me
all right so we got um
gomez stalking him again
usual flare one two you know trying to
come in
let me see let me see
nice jab right hand oh my god yo
he hits with such ferocity
the sweat that pops off for cutter's
head
when gomez hits them is nuts
you know they're gonna have to give out
smocks like when you go watch galago
live that they put the the plastic top
on the first three rows any time gold
mix
oh my god his over the head is crazy
oh man left hook right hand gomez is
mauling him in the corner pushing him
back uh koto is still doing sneaky
punches inside i'm not gonna lie koda
knows how to survive uh in the face of
uh danger
the wide stance gives uh a gomez pause
so he's not regularly running in but um
what koda does is he pulls back after he
throws his shot
and he leaves his chin up
and that's when gomez lands shot so
gomez lands a one two and he backs off
for him but he's pressing him again in
the corner so it's like um
mental pressure that he's putting no
encoder koda still is like he looks like
a street fighter he looks like a a
fighting streets type of character
it's crazy he doesn't look like a box as
all as far as his hands as his hands is
down to his waist
and um gomez lands a short left hook on
the inside
uh while they up against the rope
gomez is pushing koda is doing work
inside
and um giving him a left hook again
and uh gomez is trying to go to the body
gomez
swings while he misses koda catches him
with a shot inside really doesn't do too
much damage but again kodo is still koda
koda is still working
right while you're there and and a right
hand left hook um from gomez
round stops there they fight from bell
to bell
this is not there isn't they showing
david benedict vidas right now there has
not been a dull moment in this fight at
all i'm not gonna lie this is probably
this is what wakes up the crowd this one
kid's crowd young tiger out here let me
see king be real if you were in phil
spencer's uh position would you have
done anything differently
i don't know what to do differently i'm
not in this position i don't know all
the stuff that he has in front of him to
be honest with you
um i i can't sit there and say oh do
this and do that but i know i can listen
to the man's words and the man said if a
game doesn't ready it's not ready to
ship it's not going to ship that's it
and they're going to put it right back
in the bushes but back to these fights
though
let me see benavidez look real confident
he should look real confident tonight
because he is the watchman caller he's
the a side he's the plus side oh young
tiger came out that corner boy
boy he got a face on him man yo
oh man let's see let's see let's see
gomez all right so they back in the
middle of the ring gomez is um he's he
has a lot of different styles so he's
going to a high guard right
high guard jab off
and he's moving in closer behind the jab
all right so koda is actually getting
relaxed it's round five koda's actually
getting relaxed and he fought out of the
corner opposed to being led in the
corner so gomez is taking more of a
counter puncher uh position right now
he's like leading him in
and he's throwing the right hand but
he's throwing the right hand down he's
not throwing it straight across if he if
they tell him to throw it straight
across to uh kota's uh face or his
shoulders he will land on his target
opposed to throwing down but he's used
to doing that motion
all right so koda looks like he has a
little bit more of a handle on the
situation on what's going on he's
jabbing
still with his awkward stance his hands
is here when he's throwing and he's
jabbing out here but he's still keeping
his awkward stance here
tiger uh tiger young gomez has uh
different uh styles that he does he does
the philly crab style he caught uh kota
with a short right hand on the inside
back to the body back to the body
and he has him up against the ropes
oh gomez does he's holding him with one
hand hitting him with his free hand
while koda goes up the middle with his
shots
let's see let's see
uh
gomez backed off him for a little bit oh
koto has landed five shots straight to
gomez's body
and uh
brought some punches up the middle
he caught him with a stiff jab uh gomez
catches him with a right hand and leans
on him
in the corner kodo he does
uh cena's starting to see a little bit
of fatigue on the hands of
gomez he he's doing a lot of movement
and remember this whole time koda was
taking shots
not really delivering how much energy
was he using to be honest with you
let's see
so
again so koda is catching uh gomez with
the jab coming gomez is ripping hard
shots he's the one landing the harder
punches
all right the more telling shots
so he's standing there in the corner not
doing too much
but you can see kodona is waking up
right so whatever awkward style he does
have he's actually being a little bit
fluid with it he's starting to settle
into his style of fight
all right so gomez just missed another
shot uh koda looks like i can't get it
out of my head like a animated character
from a fighting game
but um gomez is landing a little bit of
telling shots and that's about it round
is over that was the most tame round in
in this fight so far to be honest with
you
excuse me that was round five
definitely dope
oh remember
uh watermelon margaritas
what did my boy say
he working
let me see let me see what you got what
you got
better read as we go up and you see him
code is slapping him with these punches
yeah
i don't think uh dookie kids i don't
think um is it's uh any need to put no
naughty dog on notice with the next
hellblade uh two different type of games
to be honest with you if you just said
that with um
tomb raider i would probably say that
but um hellblade
has to show me that it's on on naughty
dog's level i mean ninja theory is dope
but uh naughty dog is a different type
of beast let's let's keep it a buck
let's be for real about that
all right so
they back at it and now
uh gomez is uh showing a jab he's
showing a different type of jab he has a
little bit more bounce in the step i
guess they told him he took the round
off
all right so koda uh
is um
defensively fighting his awkward style
see
yeah i would i would have thought that
yeah cody would have got that last round
as well
let's see
um
wow
he's tripping over coda's feet because
he has this really wild stance not in
the center of the ring which favors coda
koda is his his awkward his awkward
style is actually working
um gomez is uh he's dialed it back a
little bit i guess trying to conserve
energy i guess he figures that this is
going to go 12 rounds so he doesn't want
to punch himself out
all right he's catching them over the
top they're back into the corner
gomez is back into a high guard
while
uh koda is still with the awkward punch
and it's slapping shots that he does but
these slapping shots then he he mixes it
with a looping right hand
koda
gomez still keeps trying to hit coda
and koda spins out of the way
and he keeps his eyes open the whole
time his style works for him so i don't
know if the referee is going to call it
but it's a backhand
that um
koda is throwing he's not throwing a
traditional jab he's throwing a uh a
backhand a reaching backhand
and that's illegal
all right so i don't know if he's going
to call him on it if he's going to say
anything because he has it
but uh you have uh
whatchamacallit leaning watching them
[Music]
let me see
let me see okay
not too much of anything
you have uh gomez stalking him gomez has
been stalking him this whole round
uh with jabs and overhand rights to the
and you know taking them back from one
corner to the next corner while uh koda
does flicking jabs and a right hand that
that follows and he does slapping
punches to the body
all right so again right now
when they're in close
code will let his hands go
all right let's see let's see
jabs from uh gomez and he tries to
overhand right he keeps looping and
missing it coda is doing work inside
while in close
and gomez has to
grapple with him and and he has to start
shooting to the body there you go
they're back in the corner and the round
is almost over oh right hand
he caught him again with a smooth right
hand and he's that's what he's used to
he's used to throwing that right hand
down gomez is and he caught koda at the
end of the round with that right hand
going down let me see give kodo around
as well
yeah
let me see that king you've heard
anything about
uh bite memory infinite hey stop
stealing my points brother stop stealing
my points cause i'm telling my points i
said bright infinite memory was supposed
to bend out already right and if
anybody's looking at what's going on
with the show check out the the show
tomorrow the show tomorrow we're gonna
have we're gonna be talking about a lot
of things and yeah lurch got a chin man
coda got a chin
young tiger looks
he looks happy to be here remember when
you used to see tiger woods and he used
to be like the most happy guy on the
golf course
smiling
happy to be at work
yo i love this kid's energy i love gold
mez's energy
i'm not saying coda's a slouch coda's
not a slouch coda's here to work
all right so
they made sure they d through a bunch of
water in the corner in their coda so
they can get this to stop
do i have a website for my statue yeah
logicgaming.net
you can go there you can check out all
that stuff uh go go look at um our once
you remember and subscribe to ireland's
podcast all you got to do is go look at
all my old kos
uh and and check out my old chaos king
of the statues it's coming back
but it's going to be live and remember
guys this is gonna be a calling show in
a minute so y'all guys are gonna be
calling in
and we're gonna be talking
we're gonna be having this conversation
all right so right now so uh coda is
urging
um
gomez to come on and attack him in the
corner
while
kodo is trying to
counter punch
uh gomez gomez is uh pressing the attack
he's
going to the body and cotto fights out
of the corner throwing a couple of
punches
um i don't agree with the scorecard
steve i wouldn't give cuda that last
round i would give the last round again
to gomez um
i think gomez is winning
uh five rounds to one
let me be honest with you
oh but again they're back in the middle
of the ring the center of the ring and i
think in the center of the ring
cuddle does his best work
all right um because he throws this
long jab
and it just hits uh gomez and gomez is
stalking without the jab at times he
does a lot of posture and a lot of
fainting
and um cotto just landed a couple of
shots but gomez doesn't like it goes
right to the body pushes kodo uh koda to
the ropes
and
he goes right back to the jab uh gomez
does a one-two keeps it long
pause right hand left hook he catches
him
uh gomez does oh nice uppercut
from gomez i mean from um coda
on the inside see a koda does sneaky
inside work
with oh
smooth right hand
and that froze coder from gomez
but again
koda
does work to get gomez off of him
and
gom akota does a lot of
work while they're in close he knows you
would think kota being the taller
fighter the longer fighter that he would
fight at a distance he's not he's
actually more comfortable fighting
inside
and then that's really weird it would
really throw you off a nice body shot
from koda
uh
this is the first time he's pressing the
attack on gomez and he has gomez on his
back foot
koda does he's moving his hands around
now koda um gomez takes the lead again
and pushes koda back against the ropes a
little bit
right hand over the top from
gomez gomez is stalking him one two
again
again i give this round right here
dakota um so i give it two rounds to
five
so far in favor of gomez
let me see i want you to show us
how to shop
for our own statues what to look for
what not to look for
i would like you like for you
there's nothing
like a nice drink in a fight talk that's
what's up thank you sp
yo um yeah i'm gonna show y'all uh you
know what statues and stuff i wanted to
do
i wanted to come back with kos
uh with the dr strange statue i have
right here you know because the doctor
strange movie is out
but
it's gonna come in time uh i thought it
would be here in in may to be honest
with you but again you got to get one
off the ground first you start working
with one and then you can move it into
the other but the next one is going to
be a seamless one so it'll be calling
over there as well
uh but i'm i'm gonna show y'all exactly
what to look for but remember the
ultimate taste is your taste and your
taste is king so you're the king of your
own statues and that's what king of the
statues is you know to be honest with
you 100
your display i got some great guys out
there i like i got my guy junior i got
my guy mojo they have some a hell of a
statue of setups and collections
and it's it's beautiful stuff to see
um
you know oh my god left hook from
from gomez gomez does some stuff when he
gets happy when he lands a good shot
and gomez is defensively responsible
he just threw a nice uh uppercut court
coda against the ropes and a right hand
right after but coda goes right back to
the body and he's throwing these digging
shots as he holds on
very good stuff i cannot lie
nice jab from um
gomez right hand
and koda does work on the body again
nice jab from gomez
nice jab he's jabbing well
all right cool nice jab
nice jab there in the center of the ring
gomez is going to the body while uh
i mean um
koda's going to the body while gomez is
holding him behind the head
all right okay koda does a one two three
and goes straight to the body
uh gomez straight right hand he's
ripping shots these are telling shots
now that uh gomez is throwing very
powerful shots
very powerful shots late in the fight
can take a toll on the fighter this is
the eighth round he caught him with a
one two three gomez did very powerful
jab uh kodo's against the ropes and um
gomez lands a right over the top he's
smiling at him
and uh koda is game and throwing punches
i mean
these punches are landing not saying
that they're powerful but they are
landing and they're they're definitely
trying to oh
what a body shot from gomez uh he has
caught up against the ropes he lands a
right hand on the left hook i don't know
if uh koda gets out the this round but
koda
is fighting back it's a beautiful stuff
to see right hand from gomez
very strong jab very strong jab
very strong right hands very strong left
hooks this guy is a very strong fighter
all his tippy toes
all right um
he's moving in and out
uh nice jab and he's stepping behind the
jab
if you squint your eyes he looks like in
some forms roy jones beautiful left hook
right hand oh my god these right hands
the referee has to look at this guy all
right coda finally holds
a and the round is over
and and coda's holding on to the ropes
cotto is out of his feet all right i'm
not gonna lie he took uh some shots in
that round carter did um that's strong
look at that strong jab very strong jab
push quarterback
very strong jab young tiger woods came
out there to kill
king as xbox supporter does microsoft
uh
contact you sometimes dude contact me
no
do i know people that work at microsoft
yeah
um do we talk stuff yeah but most of the
time i'm not even talking video games
most of the time we talking about life
um
the slogan is time that mark one for
what's that
let me see looking into the
song
oh okay okay
he said that's a hell oh there's a hell
of it
oh okay that's a hell of a statue slogan
that i got i always say that at kos
all right so round nine comes out uh
gomez is going right back at him because
he knew that he had him in trouble
and um
carter's moving from left to right
trying to
you know just clear his head
trying to prolong it
uh gomez is has a hop to his step
the floor is a little bit wet he tell
him come on man let's go let's get to it
left hook to the body from gomez
one two from qatar
trying to you know just keep him away
gomez is stalking them tell them come on
look at that jab jab very strong
powerful jab from gomez i really like
this gift
very strong very strong jab very strong
jab whoever faces kid is going to have
hell on their hands
to be honest with you he can only get
better
beautiful left hook
codel is no slouch he just landed like
eight shots to the body when they land
when they get in close
eight shots
basically but they're slapping punches
nothing really behind it
did it just freeze that's ridiculous
come on
don't be doing that
all right cool there we go
uh coda spun off the ropes gomez is
stalking him aggressively ala mike tyson
and he slows down
oh nice left hook he stepped in it with
the body i love the outer left hook look
you that's what you practice on the back
you practice that left hook on the back
you know just stepping with it while
you're moving
very good feel to it
all right so um
there he's stalking uh dakota is not
really engaging code is trying to
survive
uh and when a fighter is trying to
survive you know it's not really much
you can do to be honest with you unless
you set them up properly
all right so nice jab from um gomez
chasing coda back
a nice jab
and caught us back to pulling up his
tighty shorts
all right yeah and uh
oh nice right hand he rolled with a shot
from co dakota through a right hand he
rolled with it gomez did and shot a shot
of his own
that's a catch and pitch uh practice you
roll with it on your shoulder and you
just spin off it as a time and thing as
it comes in you roll pop and go right
back with it when that hand is pulling
back you're going right back with it
straight right hand
he landed on um coda caught us
complaining about it or back of the head
it wasn't
in the round is over so we're going into
the last round folks i never thought
that this fight will make it to the last
round
and it does
huh
really good fight to get to the last
round right let me see
this is only gomez six pro fight and
he's 24.
yeah he's gonna be a problem
yeah this is going to be a problem
the reference out there talking about yo
you know he can't be taking punches like
that man
this is the 10th round boy if you don't
get out of my
face six pro fight and he's on the
undercard of a pay-per-view for showtime
that lets you know in in
that boy is a beast
that boy is a
beast
that'll let you know
that'll let you know
that he's knocking people out
in in in training camps and sparring
and he's in the gym his name ring bells
let's see let's see let's see
i do apologize for that
that's this uh dry should have broke ah
yes
agua
your mouth get dry
from the watermelon oh my god what his
leg got caught up all right so he caught
um koda with the left hook right hand
and coda stumbled into the back of the
ropes and he moved back uh
awkwardly
so uh gomez uh
jumped on him
pretty decent pretty decent right hand
left hand right hand from gomez
left hand right hand from gomez gomez is
uh moving away from him awkwardly i
don't know i mean um koda's moving away
from gomez awkwardly i don't know if
gomez
caught him flush
if he's if he's if kodo's acting
but koto is not um engaging and he's
bouncing awkwardly
he's he's engaging to get gomez off of
him but gomez is still stalking
nice one too
right hand from gomez
let me see
he's stalking him he's stalking him oh
nice right hand
from gomez beautiful stuff beautiful
stuff
hmm
okay we're gonna this this is gonna
reach the bell
because uh kodo's not really engaging
to be honest with you he doesn't want
engaged in
in this and i i i don't i don't blame
him
gomez is trying to catch him nice body
shots and he has uh coda in the corner
trying to land shots
uh go coda grabs on
and he releases his hand i don't know
why he did that he should have held on
to the ref showed up
uh gomez is right back to stalking him
and hitting one with a right hand over
the top left hook to the body right hand
to the body
oh left right
from coda
the referee is watching
you know making sure that he's fighting
because this guy's taking too many shots
um
gomez's stalking quarter
again
pretty decent nothing nothing too much
all right
all right
nothing too much again
coda
oh nice good stiff jab from gomez
oh left
right hand from gomez gomez up to the
end of the bell
is trying to end them the round is over
and then
look at that
one hell of a fight fight is over
gomez a star is born beautiful beautiful
fighter
hard to knock out someone who knows the
game plan that's right
just turning in how long has uh koda
been
on his shield
just tuning in
um
koda's dakota's been uh boxing
on his back foot for a minute but again
at the same time
uh gomez
gomez is he's an absolute monster he's
an absolute monster
fuzzy bell video was good
thank you guys for answering them we got
38 watching we got 61 likes that's
what's up share that out tell somebody
tell a friend and tell a friend to tell
a friend another friend how about that
this this kid is a problem
he's a problem
you get all right so look how strong his
back looks right
and that's not
lifting any weights
um that's just look at him
he's strong he's naturally just strong
and he follows the jab
yeah okay so yeah he didn't hit he
didn't hit koda at all with that shot
but he has a very very strong jab very
strong posture he moves how
you want your fighters to move he acts
like how and and performs like how you
want your fighters to perform
he's he's
very energetic very enthusiastic
um very sound fundamentally and very
aware inside the ring of what's going on
at all times that's all you ask
you that's all you ask so they you know
go to go to scorecards we all know gomez
one if they try to rob him that's
ridiculous um
let me see david haney what do you think
about uh devin haney dad being able to
go to australia
okay um i don't know all the particulars
about it but the fact that he wasn't
able to go over that i think had
something to do with vaccinations
and you've got to make choices
uh
yeah your son is making six figures
i don't know if
what the case may be if it's vaccination
make sure everybody's up to snuff
your son's making more than six figures
man
if if this is the goal then you know
sacrifices got to be made and a lot of
times uh
you have to ask yourself
what's worth what you know um
so i i don't know i don't get in the
middle of that you know i just talk to
fights when the fights come up
oh
yeah yeah yeah
dominicano
he's dominican
yo i think he's dominican
all right so uh
i looked over and he's speaking espanol
[Music]
i don't know i don't know i think he's
dominican yo if he's dominican you got
one dominican republic you got one
this boy's gonna be a problem i gotta
check what flag did he have did he come
in the ring with is he is he cuban
colombian
what's going on
i'm gonna tell you right now if he
dominicans
they got one i mean whatever whatever
nationality is they got one but you know
a lot of times dominican uh
athletes go to you know baseball let's
let's keep it up messed up playing man
any better than these dominican kids
playing on baseball
did you get an athlete like that boxing
a dominican athlete like that boxing
if he is
good god yes let's go
i thought cuban
he looked the minute kid though right
hey i think he cuban
fifty dollar super chat
from my booboo she going crazy
[Laughter]
stop spending my money stop spending the
drink money bobo
[Laughter]
[Music]
my wife is bugging
hold on
[Laughter]
yo
my phone goes off and it's like yo you
purchased a super chat
[Laughter]
imma beat you up
yeah he could be my mono he could be
cuban
i think i gotta check it but i'm gonna
tell you right now this kid this kid
look at he told you what he came out to
do he told you he came to steal the show
he came out to steal the show
i love that look how enthusiastic he is
look how happy he is to be there
that's so beautiful that's so beautiful
that's a beautiful thing man god bless
god bless on him on his journey man
he's from havana he's cuban okay yeah
well cuban you know what it is
he's a cuban that looks dominican
like young tiger woods look look yo look
how happy his smile is infectious that
boy is marketable something crazy
look at him
beautiful beautiful i love that i love
that i love i love i love everything
about his boxing persona his eagerness
yo
you can tell that you know when he walks
in the gym he walks in with a smile he
it's infectious it's it's a beautiful
thing to see i think that's something
that you need to have remember always
talking about being happy when you go to
work we know he happy going to work
right now right he loved his job
i mean i have paid much in the beginning
but it's gonna pay off in the end this
boy hitting like that
this boy's good
that is no lie
man that is absolutely no lie i love
everything about his style
you know what's crazy
he doesn't have the cuban boxing style
cuban boxes are known to be slick
boxes
not
um fierce punches
well you know casamayor is uh is is in
his corner so he taught him a lot of
things i'm pretty sure
uh but that's they also known as being
six boxes very technically sound
uh
you know like uh guinness uh
is is very technically sound very very
fundamentally uh grounded uh as far as
um
uh boxing punching goes and knowing
distance knowing when that's so all that
stuff that we was talking about is all
the stuff that manifested itself inside
the ring because that's all the stuff
that we saw him do so it does make sense
um him being a cuban fighter that he
displayed all those attributes of the
cuban boxing system
very beautiful to see but he's a little
bit different a little bit cut above
because um he's a very
good hunter stalker and that was very
good to see
oh
no doubt man no doubt sp let me see
haven't watched him before he doesn't
seem to fight like your olympic style
that's what i'm talking about and see i
was just saying that without even
watching your joint what's going on
sorry
casamayor versus floyd fight is a wish
tapping back in the day
yes
and the fact that it didn't
yo see this is what i'm talking about yo
they're showing rolly right now right
they're showing a rolly tank and
rowley's body
isn't
the body that he's showing now i'm not
saying that he wasn't strong
all the way through he's been strong all
the way through his body has been
growing
but
now his body has
has manifested himself uh tank
tank looks fantastic as always but he is
a little soft around the middle
you know um
rolly is a power puncher
unorthodox power puncher can he takes
tanks shot
and then can take can't take his shot i
mean listen
rolly's been asking for this fight for
forever right
um
be careful
what you asked for
because you might just get it
and now he got it
but you talking about the younger
physically uh stronger fight as fighter
as far as um
imposing wise right
i i don't know man
next week is gonna be crazy remember
next week we ain't gonna be here i'll
probably give a little little brief
synopsis and give my prediction but
i already told you i'm throwing a
hundred dollars
on rolly
just in case baby just in case
all right so you got david benavidez
looking how david benavidez looks he's
always looks like a swimmer he's always
has a body of a swimmer
never too uh
chiseled
um
but i love how david benavidez fights
you know um
he he
he fights at his distance very long
very striking shots very good i remember
seeing him and i was like uh this kid is
definitely gonna be very good but he had
to maintain his um
his weight and stuff like that let me
see
you know
rolly rolly talks with us that's the kid
did they you know he's like keith
thurman
the kid that got teased in the yard a
little light-skinned kid with the list
he fighting all day he figured that hey
i know how to fight now
so all right so they doing the haircut
right now
for david benavidez they don't want them
to get in the ring too early it's 12
o'clock they should be walking into the
ring right now this is ridiculous
if tank i let him say if i was on tank
team going to action for additional pspt
uh pd uh testing
um
can't give additional
right you can only give exactly the pd
uh testing that they call for so if they
do an olympic style pd testing remember
that comes out of the fighters
that does not come out of the
promotional
both fighters got a sign of that
both fighters gotta pay for that all
right so
again it's up to them
you know i i don't know i
i know if tank didn't agree
boy you don't open the board the door to
rolly call up manny pacquiao allegedly
and uh
that's how you start looking like that
boy because rolly looks diesel right now
he look bigger than benavidez benevitas
is a heavier fighter
let me see
it's in the contract
i know i know p d
p
p
p d testing this and
yeah p d testing is in the contract but
what testing is in the contract
rolly hogg right now this is facts
i give mo rolling mo he's a bigger
puncher than tank has fought i got is
really too big at the weight class yo
you're saying everything that i'm saying
uh
liberty uh
he uh contrarian
he is bigger he's younger
i don't know
who hits harder
but he's one of the bigger punchers the
tank has fought right
so when we when we go looking at that
aspect of it
the youth
um the ability to tap into the fact that
he has
no losses
all right somebody owes gotta go next
week
you have two
guys there
with no
losses that don't know how to lose
who's going to teach who how to do what
i know is going to have to be somebody
that's going to get separated from that
consciousness i know that fight ends in
a knockout i know that fight does not go
12 rounds rolly versus tank
so
the question is who gets to knock out
early
i think from one to three
you got to get rolling
after that all tank
but wouldn't it be something crazy
if rolly catches tank in like the fifth
round
how does rowley how does tank do
you know what what what happens
what what's what's what's the thought
process when he gets hit by somebody
with the power of rolly what's what
what's what's up we don't know these
things this is why we watch
he said muscles don't win fight skills
do
yo doogie
i mean uh rich boy
100
he said if you combine rolly lips and
tanks will carefully
you get a number one single on the
billboard chart you're ridiculous
listen
muscles don't
win fights
but if you see somebody that you've seen
fight before
and their
body looks like it's in condition
some of the best condition that they've
been in in their life
then
you ask yourself this
can he apply the conditioning
inside the normal environment that we've
seen him in
it can only be a plus right it can't be
a minus that he's in the best shape that
we've seen him in
and he's in his youth
that has to be there has to be some
credit somewhere but you're right skills
do pay the bills
james tony will come out of retirement
and whip half the people in the world
right now
um
you
got to give him a little bit of credit
here i don't know i think i think rowley
like i said i give him one to three one
and three to get him out of there if he
doesn't then boom
so call addict bef before you crash
muscles slow you down
in a few rounds
they turn into weights
you already
he said call attic before you crash
huh
rolly been eating
what via vargas
did before the lawyer
oh i gotta call attic
okay
i guess
i'm not going to sleep i'll be up until
the podcast
oh he said call i'll call you before you
go to bed and no doubt i got you
but i ain't going to bed so i just call
you right after the podcast
that's cognito
all right so david lemieux just walked
inside the ring and he has a velvet uh
robe
which looks very swanky that's like
something that you wear around the house
looks dope
velvet uh blue and gold
very nice very nice look like the
escalade that i was looking at today
blue and gold blue and gold little
speckles
very nice
let me see uh contrarian i'm still not
fully sold on tank though i just feel
like floyd and al trusted him
here that for garcia danny okay so
the fact that he didn't fight uh devin
haney loma and the rest of them that has
all and first of all
garcia is fighting nobody
all right so
let's stop
he was he was ordered to fight uh
isaac isaac cruz he made sure that that
he put a petition that the wbc pulled
that out
let's stop
all right uh garcia's fighting nobody
let's talk about the real fighters out
there right loma
is is with espn and with top rank that
fight is not happening all right and
don't tell me because tia female put
himself in position tino fema was with
uh top rank when he got that fight so
all right so loma's off the shelf so
we're looking at david
devin haney devin haney is with the zone
devin haney had a contract that he uh
went into business with with the zone
that prices him out
okay you can't give devin haney 12
million dollars if the the car doesn't
call for him to get 12 million dollars
so
yeah is is a proper matchmaking from
tank uh to the fights that he has yeah
inside the uh the people that fit
remember boxing is a business at the end
of the day so at the end of the day you
have to look at who's available for what
price and how can we make this fight
work uh competing platforms do not
really deal with other competing
platforms that's why i don't like it
oh
okay
oh it's attic
oh i thought i thought it was barry
i got you at it
i got you i got you
loma's still in the ukraine yeah yeah it
was whatever i still remember fernando
vargas interview where he was like yo my
body looks like this because i've been
taking vitamins yeah you've been taking
those vitamins that go on on the back
side of your cheek muscle
allegedly
so we got benavidez that just stepped in
the ring
uh i love his uh robe
nice uh beautiful colors
uh red
green
yellow
beautiful colors beautiful colors
i don't know if that's uh
uh alligator skin
very nice very nice
i hope it ain't snake skin if i love
snakes so please please do not do not be
killing the snakes
very dope very dope
all right so he's you know swinging his
hands this center third very good
we're gonna see a different level of
um
what can i say we're gonna see a
different level
of technicality right now because we
have two champions
or one former champion and one champion
uh
actually getting to this fight right so
really good
can't wait for this fight and and i
really want to see david benefit his uh
stick to his word then david benavidez
is 25 years old lemieux is 33.
you know david is tall uh
you know the weight is fine he has a
longer reach we know that um
33 years old you start to hit the
the brick wall you start to hit that
wall
and um
can uh lemieux
uh rise to the occasion tonight
uh can he test uh
benavidez chin
i don't know
benevitas is gonna make short work of
lemieux
uh too strong for david and this is late
in his career
yeah josh you're right uh i i i think
that
i believe that
rattlesnake tastes good yo listen dookie
kicks we're gonna be doing that over
here
let me see
vargas retired at age 27.
he was putting the
lions in very young
yeah man
he was remember he was fighting in
mexico and all that other stuff very
early
yeah
see mac
i think if he can catch him at the end
of his punches he can get him out of
there and like by six rounds um
it's really
it's this fight really hinges on
what benavidez uh i mean what well not
what benavidez shows up but what um
lemieux shows up
benavidez has been pretty consistent
in his career
he has been a good boxer puncher
keeps you at distance with his punches
knows his range
he's he he pretty much knows himself
inside the ring
so we have
lemieux
what the mu is going to show up is it
going to be the aggressive lemur is it
going to be the lemur who boxes is it
gonna be the muted that showed up for
triple g that didn't take the the bull
by the horns and and and
go for greatness
does he go for greatness tonight
uh i if if you asking me to put my money
down my money down i'm gonna put my
money down on david benavidez by late
knockout
he's i give him
eight round eight eight nine round
knockout uh
if uh lemieux can
uh lemieux comes to fight
if lemieux is soft like his body
indicates to me
he's his body is soft he's dry
he has four losses
um i said he can go to sleep within uh
three to six rounds you know
from from three to six
let me see
bone what's good shout out to bone slave
cali family was good love all day
um
tough scrappy that's right dookie kicks
terribly so
yeah yeah he's technical and he's
powerful you said you got a ko in around
six with benavidez yeah
they both look dry
um
[Music]
this is true david doesn't look like
he's uh
he's waiting and i guess the fact that
he probably has vaseline on the face
makes him look a little bit more
uh sweaty than
could be the air conditioner in the
place i don't know i doubt it
i honestly believe
that both of them didn't warm up
as much as you wanted them to
so i don't know
quite possibly
quite possibly a early round if somebody
gets caught cold
so let's say uh
lemieux comes out and catches david colt
that's crazy
it's possible
all right so let's get it let's see
let's let's all right so the fight is
gonna restart right now and uh they just
went to their respective corners they're
getting ready to come out right now so
you have uh benavidez bouncing
and you know david lemieux is bouncing
right now so we're gonna go we're gonna
stay with uh
benavidez and let me i'm not gonna boot
david david
all right so
lemieux comes out with a nice stiff jab
and you can see the
it's the size difference is evident
all right it's huge
david benavidez looks like he's towering
over lemieux
and lemieux is trying to get inside and
david b benavidez is uh shooting his jab
benevitas throws a left hook that hits
the gr uh the guard or lemieux
lemieux throws a one two
tries to back uh benavidez up
and lemieux uh
is is attacking david he catches david
up against the ropes he lands a one two
david spins off the ropes throws a jab
nothing too much
you know but david is establishing that
jab and a one one two
right hand to the body of lemieux
let me throw the right hand back at the
body of
uh benavidez
so they're both jabbing lemieux is
actually
using the jab to perfection his jab
um
benavidez is
a little bit more versatile in his
offense
opposed to
lemieux
nice jab
from benavidez
and he's
he tried to uppercut
um from distance very dangerous lemieux
has been avida's back against rhodes
benavidez back has been up against the
rope three times so far in the match
and
nice jab from uh benavidez
he's trying to
keep it um
at distance
okay so lemieux catches david benavidez
with a left hook while then
benavidez throws uh a right hand
all right let me go to the body
and try to go back to the head
nice uh body shots from the view
benavidez throws a one two
catches
lemieux on the air nice too
from you lemieux i mean from benavidez
nice jab nice under
left hook uppercut from uh benavidez
right hand from benavidez benavidez now
is stalking lemieux
and he throws another right hand over
the top lemieux fights back off the
ropes
to get it back in the center of the ring
benavidez is thrown to one two with
perfection and trying to sneak in a left
hook nice jab there's an up jab
then the middle ring he caught lemieux
lemieux is going to sleep the fight is
over
the fight is gonna be over and he's he
is landing shots on lemieux
he is hitting lemue
all over the place the round stop he
caught lemieux with that right hand
lemieux don't know what century he is
he's in jesus
jesus
hit him with that shot boy their
forehead said
so disgusting absolutely so disgusting
nice right hand right over in two rounds
diggle shelly
hey man whoever called it earlier than
that
used the winner
chicken dinner
lemieux was sleeping
he's in his corner he's sleeping
so
we know lemieux came to get the check
les pills
watching back and forth
benavidez
eat his cornbread
benefit he's gonna eat his cornbread
you're gonna eat his cocktail fruit
i said you're gonna give me your
cocktail fruit
it's on my drink homie
all right so they back out lemieux comes
swinging at him benavidez goes right
back at him
oh my god that jab buckled them you
lemurs out there swinging
he quoted he got caught with a right
hand again
david benavidez dropped him with a left
hook fight is over man the fight is over
he got to be over man lemieux is back up
[Music]
oh let me try to catch him with a right
hand
lemieux was fighting though lemieux is
fighting
benavidez is catching him with the left
right hand
he's bringing the punches up and over
lemie was trying man
you gotta respect him he's trying
oh my god oh body shots the body shots
were hurt the mute is caught over his
eye
uh david benevide is landing some
monstrous shots
monstrous shots
um those body shots is what's telling
oh man disgusting
lemurs trying but um
david benavidez has him up against the
ropes lemieux is trying to fight off the
ropes his legs into there
uh
benavidez is coming up with the shots up
through the middle and he's trying to
catch him with the left hook the same
left hook he's practicing in the
background he catches lemieux with a
uppercut lemieux legs isn't there
lemieux is trying though
and he's he's he's catching david with
shots but it's not shots that can
actually hurt dave oh he caught dave
with a nice punch but
uh david is back to the body
right hands left hooks
left hooks right hands
david benavidez this is just target
practice the eye is bleeding profusely
from lemur but he's not going out
lemieux is in it
100
we got oh
nice right hand left hook he caught
david benavidez with a shot david
benavidez is up against the ropes lemuel
got caught with a left uppercut
benavidez is throwing shots it punches
and bunches something terrible oh my god
yo this is a massacre
uh benavidez
is on lemieux
but lemieux is still fighting
he's still throwing him shots that
puncher's chance be talking boy
look at leymou trying it man
let me just trying it the body shots is
what hurt the most man
oh man um
there we go
there we go straight right hand from
lemieux get to the third round baby
keep that money going
[Music]
keep that money going
[Music]
lemieux made it again a little bit
further a little bit further now a
little bit further now a little bit
further
yo you can't front
lemieux took a beating he got hot that's
right boy
he got hard queen yo what's up stop the
fight nah man let that boy go out on his
shield
boy
you want to talk about hits eat all that
[ __ ] what's bananas he said oh good god
oh good god
oh his legs went to the shadow realm
excuse me
beautiful beautiful stuff oh benavidez
went buck bananas on him but his legs
left to the shadow realm
right hands crazy
left hook inside oh good god he went
down through the ropes bottom out
all right let's go third round on all
right so the money train is in we got
money let's go let go
i say from three to six if uh
lemieux is uh not here for all that
right all right let's go oh lemurs oh
what the hell
somebody charge them you up
get back on that stick david
benavidez is on it
they back in the center of the ring i'm
i'm telling you this is pretty
entertaining
because as as much as
it's the biggest difference between the
two
is the jab from benavidez
the the the length that he has over
lemieux is ridiculous
lemieux is trying
and he's in he's in the pocket
but the uppercuts uh benavidez is a very
underrated inside fighter and he's
landing shots that are very telling
inside see he switches and he he stands
over he can see everything
nice uppercut nice jab and he pushes you
back with the jab nice left hook
right hand i can see why canelo does not
want to fight benavidez
at all
and i i don't know why he doesn't call
out triple g oh my god beautiful right
hand from benavidez uh that buckles the
legs of lemieux
referee stops the fight he's just taking
a beating
this fight was only going to end in one
way it's over anybody who called the
third round who called the third round
somebody called the third round i don't
know who called the third round i saw
the third round in there uh
boy he got cooked that's right quinoa he
got cooked
david did his thing he did his thing
this is
fight wasn't in doubt
it was just how uh
lemieux was gonna work it out right
who said six xp you said sixth round
yeah i think i i think i said i uh
i wanted the best of it right i wanted
it that ninth round right it was a
brutal fight brutality
brutality
then the video is definitely a little
hey
they're not wet no i mean they're not
dry no more
all right pause let me see uh benavidez
needs to go to 175 i want to see him
versus before
no
no no no no he needs to say exactly
where he's at and fight the dudes that
he's supposed to fight let's see him
fight andrade next right let's see that
fight let's see that fight happen let's
see him fight uh charlo uh uh uh we we
not gonna do that don't go nowhere stick
your butt right here at 168 so you can
get this work man no no no no no we
ain't doing that right now no he ain't
going up to fight no bevel i know you
want canelo to get revenge you want
revenge for the canelo beating at the
hands but nobody told them to go up
there and box with the gods that's
higher than him nah canelo gonna hold
that one there uh-uh he ain't going up
there to fight bible he should have left
bevel alone now bible was coming down to
take canelo's 168 belts no
he needs to say exactly where he's at
and these dudes need to see this man
this man is a monster absolute beast
these dudes do not want no parts of
david benavidez shout out to david
bienick benavidez for getting that third
round stoppage it was brutality from
round one all the way to around the
referee said no man i love your soul man
go to
get your check cash your check so you
can count your money
very good fight yo listen guys i love
each and every last one of you we got 40
people that's watching with us right now
man share that out there friend let
somebody know what's going on we got 70
likes that's what's up man love each and
every last one of you tomorrow iron
lords podcast in the morning don't
forget oh
afternoon 1pm it's gonna be dope uh i
think this is the prediction show right
i think this is the xbox prediction show
i think it is
early stoppage uh in your opinion nah he
he was getting batted man he
uh he was getting battered with
something disgusting to see that left
hook right there that that that's a good
ref that's a good ref that's a good ref
the referee saw it you know and it is
what it is yo
catch you guys tomorrow get your rest if
you're gonna finish to get your drinks
don't say i didn't even get a chance to
finish my drink that's how good this
drink been is this drink been and this
fight has been yo thank you for hanging
out with king combat talk with the king
the professional fan i'll catch you guys
later man it was definitely
a good fight i can't front
catch you guys tomorrow
but before we go
let's hit that outro that intro
ladies and gentlemen
presents the featured event of the
evening
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting financial
swing of fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve
heaven's tipping moving like a tire
swerve out here acting bad thank you
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie captain you were phony homie
now you owe me action have him sinking
tony tony tony braxton and they all want
to talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got hands so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
red you could dance to redemption
[Music]
you